fun
[Musique]
nous
c'est
[Musique]
circulez a pris pour les habitants de
tokyo eux aussi la forme d'une aventure
quotidienne à l'intention de ces
malheureux piéton aux prises avec
quelques 400 mille véhicules
on a récemment installé un système de
panneaux lumineux indiquant seconde
après seconde
le maigre laps de temps restant pour
traverser sans danger
[Musique]
moyennant ces signaux moyennant aussi
les pédales à déclenchement automatique
les piétons de tokyo peuvent encore
exister à paris qui compte un million de
voitures ce sont les automobilistes qui
devrait s'étonner de pouvoir encore
circulé c'est entre les voitures de la
préfecture de police constitue autant d'
agences de renseignement pour le poste
centrale de commande véritable
dispatching de la circulation
[Musique]
un embouteillage et il signalé le poste
de commande qui dispose d'un plan
général de la signalisation va par
l'intermédiaire d'un jeu de contact
électronique changer le rythme des feux
de signalisation du secteur
[Musique]
mieux encore sur un itinéraire donné une
[ __ ] enregistre le flot des voitures
et communique automatiquement les
renseignements au poste central
celui-ci modifiera en conséquence les
temps d'arrêt sur l'itinéraire en
fonction du trafic
c'est ainsi que paris possède malgré
tout la circulation la plus rapide du
monde
souvent il est plus facile de circuler
que de stationner dans certaines zones
les zones bleues la durée du
stationnement est limité à une heure
mais c'était compter sans le système d
le déplacement de voitures a fait son
apparition sur les champs elysées
[Musique]
toutes les airs il déplace la voiture de
ses abonnés et le tour paraît jouer mais
attention le fichier central des
contraventions a été doté d'un système
de classement automatique qui place
également les récidivistes et il y en a
[Musique]
qui
les brocanteurs qui t'amène derrière lui
alors voila en gros bémol où on base
pour aller directement c'est ça qu'ils
pensent
celui qui forme pour le pleurent le plus
grosse panique en paris c'est toujours
le chauffeur livreur qui est en plus mon
collègue déchets de tunisie occupe un
plus gros de colo en converse je parle
pas de la famille parle du paquet et
bien à l'écran pour être la preuve alors
exactement voilà pourquoi on perd du
temps et les livraisons et on l
embouteillage et safran suis comme ça là
ça bien qu'on est sur une grande avenue
mais 30 conduit dans une fenêtre au lieu
d'un alors les couples elton
la mairie tout ça c'est bon nous ce que
vous livrez la cdu là ouais bon pour y
travailler a livré le linge dans la
soirée par exemple à partir de 21h car
au figuré car coiffeur j'ai travaillé
toute la journée à rester ouverts pour
attendre soins
bah oui oui oui à la barre la salle
encore à y bien sûr à voir je peux plus
retors trouvé dans le sac d'oignon le
teint deuil alors là les fêtes de noël
qui arrive ça va être encore par quelque
chose de bien un groupe d'architectes
s'est penché sur le plan de paris et en
attirer quelques conclusions
rien non de plans de voyage pour voir
que tous nous sommes dans un système
avec des normes anti circulatoire si
vous voulez vous trouver devant un
système qui est entièrement électrifiée
et qui ne bougent que par accident
on peut dire qu'on n'a pas organisé la
circulation mais on à organiser
méthodiquement d'embouteillages sur
l'ensemble de la ville le principe de
notre projet est très simple ce sont des
voies circulation continue qui relie les
voies existantes actuellement arrivant
au nord de paris
27 carrière au sud de même concept de
l'ouest délaissent les piétons passent
par des passages souterrains
nous avons ici un chemin sur lequel il
faut représenter toutes les grandes
artères qui arrive à paris et leur lyon
voix du nord au sud par un certain
nombre de trajets que vous voyez ici
trajet qui existe déjà un trajet qui
utilisent des voies existantes bien
entendu c'est toujours le même principe
et est ouest dans l'autre sens comme
ceci vous retrouver par exemple ici la
voix est ouest qui est la principale
changer lisez celle ci est celle ci nous
avons par conséquent un réticule ajout
d'un certain nombre de voix est-ouest
nord-sud sur l'ensemble de la ville qui
vous définit vise la ville en un certain
nombre d' îlots de quartier les
quartiers plutôt que divo alors une fois
c'est ce quadrillage effectué une fois
chaque atelier a effectué vous nous
aménageons c'est carrefour qui sont les
carrefours à deux niveaux dont on vous a
parlé
les carrefours sont aménagés sur le
système du trèfle comme ça se passe sur
les autoroutes que tout le monde connaît
dans la ville on aura également des
cartes faut qu'ils n'auront peut-être
pas les mêmes directions que les
précédents avec des formes de voix qui
seront différentes mais le principe sera
exactement le même sinon qui utilisera
des voyagistes
vous voulez aller sur votre gauche de
l'autre côté vous prenez vous dépassez
le carrefour vous prenez cette voie de
rocade et vous tournez de cette façon si
dans l'autre sens ou françaises
utilisent vous dépasse également caron
et vous trouverez cette façon exactement
la même faune
un carrosse un instant s'efforçant de
passer dans ce grand embarras ce bien
embarrassé 20 carrosse bientôt arrivant
à la philly sont en moins de rien suivi
de plus de 1000 et pour surcroît de mots
un sort malencontreux conduit en cet
endroit un grand troupeau de b ainsi
voit l'eau en 1660 décrivait déjà les
embarras de paris en 1970 après plus de
trois siècles
il est rare de croiser des troupeaux
dans la capitale mais les embarras on ne
vous l'apprendra pas n'ont pas disparu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la région parisienne on estime
qu'il y à deux millions cinq cent mille
voitures à paris même neuf cent trente
mille voitures sont immatriculés ces
chiffres sont en constante augmentation
comme la surface des ruelles n'augmente
par les déplacements des parisiens sont
de plus en plus difficile
nous nous sommes livrés à une expérience
nous sommes quatre ici daniel durand des
claude lefebvre et pierre orofino nous
nous trouvons place pie xi et nous
allons nous rendre à la bastille avec
chacun un moyen de locomotion différents
moi même j'irai en vélomoteur daniel moi
je prends l'autobus 54e d'ici là jusqu'à
la république après ça le 65 jusqu'à la
bastille
claude bien voitures particulières par
les grands boulevards barbès
rochechouart magenta république et
bastille nucléaire le métro jusqu'à
stalingrad changement est arrivé à la
bastille l'a donc s'agir pour nous d'une
course nous partons tous ensemble et
l'on verra avec ses moyens de locomotion
quel sera le premier arrivé il est très
exactement 10h33
nous partons tout de suite en rockets
[Musique]
une première constatation sur les
grandes artères les feux rouges sont
très rarement synchronisée et provoque
une perte de temps certaines
[Musique]
pour cette expérience nous avions choisi
les meilleures conditions un jour de
semaine
en fin de matinée la circulation est
fluide aux heures de pointe
les résultats ne peuvent être
qu'aggraver
[Musique]
et ben voilà il ne fait pas chaud en
cette période henry au botteur mais on
arrive très vite de savoir qui à 12h33
tabaski si j'arrive le premier à ma
montre
10h53 20 minutes dont
officiellement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai exactement compteur trois manches
claude parti à 11h33 se paie donc albert
et quelques rabbit une demi heure pour
venir une demi heure la circulation
était relativement fluide particulier
sur les grands boulevards et
certainement qu aux heures de pointe un
doigt m
certainement le double de temps
pierre arrivé en troisième position par
le métro havas montre 11h07 donc plus
d'une demi heure 35 minutes
c'est passé très bien une attente de
cinq minutes à chaque métro et
[Musique]
non pas du tout nous ne vous pas
utiliser de taxi pour la grande majorité
des parisiens leur tarif élevé en font
un moyen de transport occasionnel
surtout pas courant daniel durand des
arrivé en quatrième position ou à 8 57
minutes pour faire le trajet mais par
l'autobus fait partie dans le même temps
que tout le monde 25 minutes j'attends
de l'autobus place clichy 25 minutes
après ça un quart d'heure pour aller
jusque-là public sans problème
changement il s'est fait un peu à peu
prend cinq minutes et dix minutes pour
venir ici vous dites 55 minutes 57
minutes exactement combien jusqu'ici
avec une circulation qui était
relativement fluide les conséquences de
cette expérience sont évidentes d'abord
dans paris le deux roues et route comme
moyen de transport en commun
le métro est sûr relativement rapide
mais à quelles conditions aux heures
d'affluence foule entassement
invraisemblable atmosphère irrespirable
en surface le service des autobus
fonctionnement les fonctionnera toujours
non il ya là un cercle vicieux les
autobus circulent mal car il ya dans les
rues trop de voitures particulières et
comme il circule mal les usagers renonce
à les utiliser et se servent de plus en
plus de leur propre voiture
c'est un paradoxe le plus sûr et fait
des difficultés de circulation est
d'inciter un nombre croissant de
personnes à utiliser la voiture
individuelle
on a créé des couloirs spécialement
réservée aux autobus
cela a amené une amélioration sensible
mais aussi certains inconvénients
ces voix sont souvent est inévitablement
obstruée et lorsqu'un camion pour
décharger ne se met pas en stationnement
dans le couloir lui même il se met à
côté ce qui provoque une gêne pour le
reste de la circulation
une information qui a priori ne semble
concerner que les parisiens c'est
pourtant un problème que connaissent
maintenant tous les habitants des
grandes villes
c'est le fameux grain de sable dans
l'engrenage de la circulation avec ses
anecdotes avec ces disputes
ce matin il fallait prendre patience
essayé de ne pas trop s'énerver ils
m'ont sergent a pu se rendre compte il
eut pourtant quelques beaux concerts
d'avertisseurs et quelques disputes vous
avez vu un instant rien de trop grave
cependant les parisiens ont essayé de
prendre tout cela avec philosophie
un autre combat décisif paris bouchon
jacques chirac ce matin propose de
nouvelles solutions pour tenter
d'améliorer la circulation dans la
capitale
il faut savoir que chaque jour paris
absorbe 7 millions de voitures vous en
doutez bien c'est énorme
et parmi les idées proposées un
gigantesque souterrain car en surface
les solutions on les connaît déjà
interdiction de stationner ou alors
parcmètres partout en big n les embarras
de paris ne date pas d'hier et déjà à
l'époque des carrosses et des charrettes
walo n'avait pas manqué d'en souligner
les tracas la situation dans le paris
d'aujourd'hui est devenu quasiment
infernale autant d'ailleurs pour
stationner que pour circuler en l'espace
de dix ans le nombre des bouchons ont
été multipliées par quatre et la ville
n'est plus en mesure de digérer le
million et demi de véhicules qui tentent
de circuler chaque jour
pour tenter d'améliorer la situation un
projet gigantesque est actuellement à
l'étude à la mairie de paris
il s'agit ni plus ni moins que de créer
un réseau d'une cinquantaine de
kilomètres d'autoroute à travers le sous
sol de la ville c'est le tracé enfoncé
qui figurent sur cette carte
il consiste en gros en un axe est ouest
1 avec desserte du centre opéra hôtel de
ville et dégagement vers le sud
si le projet est retenu il permettra be
cool man d'environ 4000 véhicules par
heure
mais il n'est pas sans inconvénients et
son coût énorme risque d'être son
principal handicap
alors en attendant et pour tenter de
parer au plus pressé
on prépare d'autres mesures interdiction
de stationner sur certains grands axes
extension du stationnement payant et
augmentation des tarifs de 6 à 8
wrangler et même différent autour de
l'étoile priorité aux autobus et
augmentation éventuelle du nombre des
taxis enfin suppression du stationnement
dans certaines rues et certains
quartiers
je pense qu'il s'agit là de sommes qui
pourraient utilement faire l'objet d'un
référendum municipal
je crois que cette technique doit être
développée sans pour autant bien sûr en
abuser et que ce sujet est suffisamment
important mobilisateur pour justifier sa
mise ans
[Musique]